the Google cloud platform channel is hit
500,000 subscribers thank you for your
continued support and growing this
community and for sharing your
excitement and curiosity around Google
cloud this year has been challenging for
everyone as we all try to adapt to the
new normal
whether you're providing your business
model learning new skills or just hoping
for a friendly 5-minute distraction we
genuinely want to help our goal is to
continue to create useful and inspiring
content for you so if there's a topic
you would like to learn about please let
us know in the comments below and be
sure to stay tuned for upcoming series
on data loss prevention best practices
when scaling and cloud functions
tutorials thank you again for
subscribing and showing your support to
show our thanks we put together some
behind the scenes footage of the
studio's that we really miss here's to
another 500 K tweak 51 take two icons
like because implementation would have
been like a problem for a minute like
illumination over clothes dang it hello
that the heroes I have a new turn it for
you developer advocate join you
challenge I can do it like this
[Music]